joining us on the mercedes-benz vans
phone line is a man who's been covering
the tampa bay buccaneers forever and a
day for the tampa bay times back here on
the program is rick stroud how are you
rick
hey rich never a dull moment how are you
doing i know that right so uh best you
can tell what happened on that sideline
in med life
yesterday with the bucks and brown
well i mean i've i've sort of
tried to piece it together as best i can
i i don't know exactly what the
conversation that
you know bruce arians and antonio brown
had on the sideline um
i can tell you that aries was asking him
what was wrong you know is something
wrong with you
um and i don't know what be
what antonio brown's response was
we know that it wasn't an injury
according to
bruce arians
they obviously have a process for that
where you go to a trainer the trainer
will tell the coach if you're out
um
you know and the next thing bruce says
because they were in the middle of the
drive you know he saw
antonio walking you know half naked
through the end zone so
you know in in aryan's mind he quit the
team now he's not being very forthcoming
obviously there was
some flash point um and maybe maybe
bruce is unaware of exactly what set
antonio off but
um
you know we saw mike evans come over
obviously and try to talk him into not
doing what he was doing and
um you know as soon as he decided to
quit
um you know i mean that that can be
interpreted as conduct detrimental
whatever and and uh we don't know if
they're gonna release him today or what
list he might wind up on but
his buck's career is is through and it's
still
you know there's still obviously a side
that that brown has not told yet
um i suppose but um you know we'll see
what he has to say if he has anything to
say at all well so um lots of questions
because based on brady's
response to it um
and you know calling for compassion
um and and also a call for brown getting
the help that he needs
along with
um
the reaction that brown had whatever the
blow up was
on a sideline
for a team that kept him despite the
fake vaccination card that he handed in
in a story that you broke a few weeks
ago
means there had to have been something
going on behind the scenes there had to
have been
something that we don't know about is
there any sense that you can give us
about what that something may be
well i i think in general and this is a
general generalization but um you know
ever since this thing happened with with
uh uh with the suspension
um i don't think antonio since he
returned felt the same relationship or
closeness with the organization for
whatever reason okay
maybe that was because
i and i don't know that the bucks are at
fault here
um
i i just i don't know how to how to
quantify that because that's that's
antonio's perception but he definitely
he definitely had a streak to him we
talked to him after the game you know
when he had the 10 catches for 101 yards
um at carolina his first game back
and he was paranoid you know he was sort
of accusatory i don't know who he was
directing at the media he said people
were trying to frame him
um you know that
talked about drama and all this sort of
thing
um but there was a general sense i think
among the team that he believed that
something had changed right that they
um you know he had the suspension i
don't know what he expected the bucks to
do about it
um he got three games not six not eight
um he continued to work out and rehab
his ankle at the facility
um but you know this guy
i mean
sort of a time bomb rich i mean he's
done this to every place he's ever been
um i don't know what his what his issues
are you know before he joined this team
it was
you know anger management and tony
robbins and i'm a change you know all
this stuff i think tom brady really
wanted him i think tom really cares
about him i think that's why tom said
what he said i don't know if tom has any
particular reasons to to be worried
about a b
uh in the short term but yeah it's just
um
you know
i guess it was inevitable but i i do
think that brown
according to some people i've talked to
you know just felt like you know things
had changed when he got back from his
suspension things had changed i mean
they they
they kept him you know and then they
used him and then they employed him and
they kept him employed and they
i mean 100 yards receiving in an nfl
game is no no small feat and he keeps
doing it and that's
i i don't understand you know which is
why leads me to believe that he might
not be able to control this
and so you know and then you see him
with his bag and he's waiting for a
driver who becomes famous because
you know they post it out there and he
doesn't seem to care that that that
that he has a hall of fame career in
front of him and can live out his days
as a hall of fame athlete as opposed to
some
guy who who reacts in a manner that
makes other people
famous for 15 minutes it just makes no
sense to me rick you know nothing
on that yeah i think you'd i think you'd
probably
need a lot of time and more degrees than
i have or you rich to try to figure out
you know what what causes antonio brown
you know to react the way he has um
you know he he um he's an absolute
talent
you know i think the bucks i think
sometimes too you know these teams see
the talent and they they really want it
right and obviously brady did and again
i'm not doubting brady's
you know sort of affinity for antonio
brown for hours short or long he was
with him in new england but i don't tom
cares about teammates you know i think
he feels he's in a position to help
people
and at this start stage of his career
that's what he wants to do
i think he tried to help antonio but in
the meantime you know tom's about
winning and he knew
he absolutely knew antonio brown would
help him and did you know and he caught
one of the touchdowns in the super bowl
and
you know he put a ring on his finger and
and so that's that's important there's a
trade-off there right
um
and i think
in my mind bruce arians absolutely would
not have would not have
uh entertained the idea of antonio brown
six months earlier he told us it was too
much diva he didn't want any part of him
if not for tom brady and you know took
him into his house the whole thing i
mean look brady has rewarded the bucks
and everybody
with the bucks you know for for pulling
off what was a remarkable
you know super bowl run so
the fact that they resigned him again it
was kind of a surprise because there's
more legal trouble and entanglements in
the off-season he was the last guy they
brought in here they waited until two
weeks and the waters had calmed down
after he settled with his trainer
um
trouble is never that far away from
antonio brown and it found them again
they took some shots for standing by the
guy
bruce in particular
and it came back to bite him and you
know
why are any of us surprised i don't know
his issues um
you know he seems very selfish to me
at times he certainly you know he didn't
help tom brady here's brady
sticking his neck out for him and
they're trailing in a game by 14 he
decides you don't want to play
i don't think that's how you reward
somebody that has gone to bat for you
you know
rick stroud tampa bay times here on the
rich eyes and show anything to the
incentives anything about that that uh
no because you know listen they um he
was very close to making a million
dollars you know a couple catches here a
touchdown there i mean a year ago they
ran with with ronald jones needing about
21 yards to get a thousand
they ran at the end of the final game of
the regular season
three two or three pop passes you know
what those are you just going motioning
essentially a glorified
frontal handoff but in the air which
accounts as a reception they ran two or
three of those to get him a quarter of a
million dollars at the end of the game
i i can't believe for a second that
you're going to do that as an
organization
and then you know say well we don't want
him we're not going to play him as much
because we don't want him to make a
million dollars man that that clearly
wasn't the case and anybody that
suggests that is kind of reaching that
that much i can assure you um why he
would leave that money off on the table
though is surprising although he hasn't
been very smart you know um getting
fined i mean i think it cost him close
to 300 000 for the the fake vaccination
card issue so
um
yeah you know ten thousand dollars to it
to a uh to a chef that he settled with
before he came back i mean
you know all these things sort of build
up there's always this sort of explosion
point you can kind of see the warning
signs and then
you know and then it happens and
you know
it's it's like i i think i said this to
you when we were texting last night
one of my favorite phrases is that
you know
you you can lay down on hay and you make
it eight hours sleep but you're gonna
wake up scratching
you know and i think the bucks are
itching pretty good today
so moving forward rick i mean the bottom
line is the two best two of tom brady's
best wide receivers it will not be
available to him fournette is banged up
levante david how do things look for
a bucks team that is definitely going to
have to play a home playoff game
in less than two weeks unless they play
that monday night or two weeks from
tonight what do what do you have for me
on on their readiness for the title
defense when the rubber meets the
playoff road
yeah i got nothing but more clouds i
mean ronald jones has an ankle they're
doing an mri on keyshawn bond has some
some rib damage
but he thinks he might be able to go
they're hoping giovanni bernard comes
back from ir i mean this thing is dark
and gloomy when it comes to weapons but
you know
tom brady does more with less and has in
his past and and you know mike evans was
out there he was playing he made some
plays
surreal cyril grayson has has come out
of nowhere lsu track star and it
suddenly looks like a
a pro bowl receiver and bashar pyramin's
made a lot of plays in this league he's
still got gronk he's still got o.j
howard he's still got cam break they're
not going to just go in the fetal
position i can tell you that
um and you know defensively they they
got to get levante back which they think
they will
um they need shaq barrett obviously
um but you know the secondary is fairly
healthy so they'll make their run i mean
you know
you've got the goat uh if they win
another game rich and if the rams lose
to san francisco who's playing to get in
the playoffs all of a sudden the bucks
have the two seed and two home games and
they'll roll the dice if they got to go
to green bay again and i think that's
the best case scenario and i wouldn't
count them out man i didn't think they
were going to go 93 yards against the
jets you know and score with 15 seconds
either yeah i know that's the jets rick
and that's the 12 number 12 uh in that
building um against the jets so come on
man i mean
no i i could have told you that you
could have texted me in the middle of
that moment i'm like the minute that the
jets went on four and fourth and two and
wound up sneaking it apparently that
apparently that was an audible that it
was supposed to go to barrios on
on one of those jet sweeps and instead
zach wilson went i mean
i could have told you that but um
so what about what about jack barrett
and levante david i mean and and and
fournette what about those three guys in
particular i think they're optimistic
they'll get them back in some some
capacity i think levante will be okay um
shaq i'm not sure about uh although i
you know it's not
it's not an injury that necessarily
would would prevent them from playing
some in the playoffs um you know the
question is
you know what
just because you're out there doesn't
mean you're effective right like you
know okay he's out there but is he able
to be shaq barrett or he's able to be
levante david so
these guys you know all got bites out of
them obviously fournette did with his
hamstring
mike has battled evans has battled these
throughout his career so he he knows you
know how to come back from him his
wasn't as severe
um they'll line up they'll all play you
know it's it's a second season as you
know rich and
um you know to have a home game these
guys have been really good at home
uh they'll figure it out you know i i i
i just you know it's been a lot of
adversity this year with the injuries
that's the only difference between the
two seasons they've actually been better
overall you know this year i think i
mean they're going to win
they beat carolina to win 13 games first
time in franchise history um you know
back to back 12 plus win seasons
brady having another i mean there's a
lot of a lot of good a lot of good
that has happened even though you know
this thing with the jets didn't didn't
look good but i i would never count them
out i swear to you i wouldn't i could i
could put holes in every team in the nfc
and show you where they're vulnerable to
so
we'll see um we'll see who they have
that's going to be the key talk
and talk about things that you can't um
make up right is that uh
maybe it's gonna be le'veon bell who tom
brady leans on because brown is gone you
know i i i
you can't make this stuff up in the nfl
so last one for you what do you think
bruce arians is thinking about tonight
when he pours himself a couple fingers
deep what do you think
what are you saying well maybe this
afternoon i don't know
it's five o'clock somewhere i know that
so
what do you think what do you think you
know what he's thinking you know what
he's thinking is one one thought rich
and he said it
he said it after the game
i've got tom brady
i've got tom freaking brady
anything's possible man he's won seven
he's been to 10. you know that's a heck
of a place to start
you gotta slay them you gotta slay the
monster you know somebody's gotta go out
there and take it from him i mean
he's unbelievable and that's that's the
you know just like yesterday and you say
well the jets you know i get that you
know what
he had tom brady so so everybody on that
team everybody on that team and in that
organization
they believe they're gonna do it they
will find a way because of number 12.
that's all he's thinking about right now
rick stroud thanks for the time let's do
it again happy new to you you and yours
appreciate it take care happy new year
you bet that's uh rick stroud nfl stroud
on twitter
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here